my name is carlson it's live on ironian
and we're joined by magnus carlson hi
magnus thank you for joining us
thank you
so how do you feel after making it
through with a record score of 34 in the
preliminaries
yeah i was uh was a very good uh scorer
was i think uh
um taking you know taking the uh
position and so on and to to account it
was on par with some of my
best
best ever
rapid round robin events so that was um
that was very good
i feel like
the quality of
my games perhaps
dipped a little bit um the last couple
today but overall uh it was very good
all right
and um you do it even with losing three
points to hans niemann with drawing from
that game i think the whole world is
wondering magnus what was the reason you
uh withdrew from my game
yeah unfortunately i cannot um
cannot particularly speak on
on that uh
but
you know people
can draw their own conclusion and
they
certainly certainly have
and
i have to say i'm
very impressed by neiman's
play
and
i think
his mentor maxim bluegay must be doing a
great a great job
okay uh can you confirm or not confirm
that it has to do with um
suspecting him
of cheating
i will not comment on that okay it's
been a dramatic time for chess and of
course
a special two weeks for you as well also
after syncful cup how are you doing in
all of this
i'm okay just you know
living living my life uh and trying to
do well in the
um
in the tournaments i mean people
people who know me and followed for
instance the tournament in in zagreb in
2019 know that i can uh
sort of shut things up
so that's
mm-hmm
and with a performance rating actually
now
of 29 39 in the preliminaries how are
you able just to stay so focused and
just play some of your best chess
well i'm
i'm you know happy to to play chess that
usually makes me
makes me happy and
as i said um
i have i have a lot of experience and
generally it makes me uh
makes me uh adaptable um but um
you know the um the score in their
preliminaries it's uh it's it's nice but
now i'm facing a very strong opponent
already in the um
in the quarters so uh
yeah it doesn't necessarily mean
anything at this point aha
and uh magnus you mentioned um
a name there i think maybe a trainer of
franz
niemann that he's doing um a good job um
can you say some more about that is is
that because you think he's helping hans
in the games
no i will not say anything more
about
about that subject will you at some
point make a comment on all the fuss
that is going on
uh yeah i hope to hope to say a little
bit more after uh after the tournaments
mm-hmm
so i'll ask you very in general magnus
because the whole world the whole chess
world the whole world actually is
talking about cheating these days is in
general cheating a problem in chess do
you think
i think
individual
people will answer the question um
[Music]
pretty
you know differently depending on their
on their own
on their own experiences
but um
i mean regardless of
whether it's it's a massive problem or
not um it's um
i think fairly uh fairly easy to
to to cheat and on general
you know
on a general basis i think that um
teachers in the in the futures uh in the
future have to be um
you know
it should not be taken uh should not be
taken lightly um neither um
online or over the board
do you have um sort of a something you
urge to say to young players playing
online who maybe are tempted to cheat to
maybe get higher rating or for whatever
reason
yeah
i understand it's um
[Music]
it's uh it's tempting but um
yeah i would wouldn't wouldn't recommend
it
is organizers is fida is are they doing
enough to um avoid cheating and to uh
you know
punish if there is a suspicion of
cheating
it's hard to um sorry to say already
would you like to see some more action
be taken in terms of cheating
yes
comment uh i you know i'll
probably um say a bit more after the
tournament
and uh whether it's on um that
particular subject or something else so
just let's see all right i'll leave it
with that finally minus you played levon
in
the quarterfinals and you've had the
chance also to play galfond ivan chuck
here in the preliminaries how you
enjoyed uh playing with these legends
um obviously the game against iranchuk
was um
was a great fight um
should have won at some point but then
he
defended very well afterwards um
wouldn't quite put lavon in um
in the same case it's turning 40 next
month actually yeah i know i know it's
it's surprising that um
he and
peter laco who um you know started a lot
earlier they're actually just three
years
three years apart but levon came into
the elite pretty much at the same
same time as i did like one year earlier
so i consider him to be sort of the same
generation um
as as i am even though he's technically
uh
technically a bit older but
yeah in general he's a super tough um
opponent it looked like he didn't have
the best tournament here then he pulled
himself together and um in any one match
he's
extremely dangerous
and we actually have five teenagers in
the knockout stage are we seeing the
start of a generation shift in chess
oh it's already um
it's not at the start it's already
happening and uh
um i feel like um
it's already kind of well known that
guys like
um by prague arjun
vincent keimer
uh that they are very uh
very strong uh but now um
you know others are are coming along as
well so
um it's certainly
certainly exciting to see and um
it's motivating for me as well yeah
very cool to hear magnus that we really
appreciate to hear your thoughts and
best of luck in quarterfinals
thank you
thanks for joining us